Republican leadership is secretly trying
to rehabilitate tier Bush also known as
AB inbev the company that makes Bud
Light you have not seen this report
anywhere because the campaign is
clandestine like so many of the
influence operations that Define our
politics I only heard about it because
some friends of mine in DC some little
birdies saw it firsthand and gave me the
heads up I'm going to start out by
saying I hope this isn't true I hope
it's a big misunderstanding and people
just saw things and heard things and had
conversations that were all a big
miscommunication because I like Kevin
McCarthy I think he's been basically
fine pretty good actually as house
speaker
and I just hope it isn't true but here's
what's happening according to credible
sources in our nation's capital A
Consulting Group named Miller strategies
is lobbying around Capitol Hill to get
Republicans to carry water forer Bush
specifically in their districts typical
lobbying no surprise there but what
makes this particular lobbying effort
different is that Miller strategies is
headed up by a guy named Jeff Miller
who's a top Aid to house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy this is a man described as
McCarthy's Field General Miller
strategies is currently squeezing House
Republicans particularly vulnerable
Republicans in swing districts the kind
of Republicans who need leadership
support and funding from those house
leadership packs and they're squeezing
them to drop the boycott of Bud Light
and start carrying water for the woke
beer company in their districts the
budlight boycott has been the most
successful conservative pressure
campaign that I've ever seen certainly
in recent memory perhaps
ever months later months into this
boycott the boycott remains stronger
Bush's stock has been decimated new
reports have just come out that budlight
is on track to start losing shelf space
at retailers this fall so this is crunch
time this is the kind of time when you
might hire some lobbyists to try to
squeeze people to stop the boycott it's
a total conservative Victory the most
effective push back yet against the
radical and now Republicans are eager to
clutch defeat from the jaws of Victory
if house leadership their enforcers have
their
way according to my friends in the swamp
Miller strategies had a big party to
inaugurate their new headquarters across
from the old Trump Hotel about a week
ago all sorts of Republican big wigs
were there and just in case any members
had not gotten the message guess what
beer they were
serving you guessed it Bud Light baby
most telling about the whole campaign
is the secrecy if you look at the Miller
strategies Client List you will not
seezer Bush listed you won't even see
their public name AB inbev well that
would look
terrible if you contact the speaker's
office if you file a foyer request
you're not going to find any emails or
meetings openly advocating for going
soft oner Bush that would look terrible
too instead it would seem that house
leadership is relying on their secretive
Force
in the supposedly private sector to put
the squeeze on our duly elected
representatives and convince them to
thwart the biggest Grassroots
conservative victory in
ages as I said to date Kevin McCarthy
has been a fine speaker he has exceeded
most conservatives
expectations and so I hope it's not true
I hope it's a big misunderstanding but
if it is true this kind of thing is
completely
unacceptable bush has never apologized
for its Embrace of the radical movement
I don't care how much money they're
paying to those Republican leadership
lieutenants around DC I don't care how
much money they're offering to throw
into elected Republicans coffers if
conservatives give up now on a campaign
so successful to fight an ideology so
dangerous and Evil we lose all
credibility in subsequent fights call
your Congressman call house leadership
call your local lobbyist tell them to
cut the crap theer Bush boycott ends
when we say it ends and as far as I have
anything to say about it I don't see any
end in sight I'm Michael nlls this is
the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 25
bucks off your order with code nolles
kwes go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles today
most men think of the Roman Empire every
single day we will get to that important
news story in just a moment first though
speaking of swampy
things a a man
disguised as security or potentially a
law enforcement officer a guy
who put on a badge tried to make himself
look like an actual security
professional who was armed with multiple
Firearms was just arrested trying to
approach Robert F Kennedy Jr at a
campaign stop in Los Angeles according
to the
LAPD oh I'm sorry according to Kennedy's
team the man claimed to be part of
Kennedy's security team told RFK Jr's
actual protectors with urgency that he
needed to be taken to the candidate
immediately observing that the man had a
handgun Kennedy's security team removed
the man from the area isolated and
surrounded him then notified
LAPD uh he was spotted and detained
before this speech that's good man was
wearing two shoulder holsters with
loaded pistols spare ammunition
magazines carrying a US Marshal B on a
lanyard and a belt clip federal ID and
identified himself as a member of
Kennedy's team then LAPD comes in LAPD
takes custody of a second man who came
to the campaign with the first guy who
got arrested protectors observed that
that man was seeking access to the event
had a backpack and that backpack had at
least one other handgun multiple knives
and some extra ammunition good thing
that Kennedy's team caught
them Kennedy has been requesting Secret
Service
protection he's a presidential
candidate sort of a major presidential
candidate presidential candidates who
reach a significant degree of notoriety
and and profile are afforded Secret
Service protection Bobby Kennedy has not
been Joe Biden has turned down that
request even as people who sure look
like Assassin
show up to his campaign events now you
might say well there's some weirdos
weirdos show up to a lot of political
events I think there should be a rule if
your father and uncle are both
assassinated while running for president
and serving as president respectively
and then you run for president I think
you automatically should be entitled to
Secret Service protection don't
you some have pointed out well a lot of
good the Secret Service did to his
father and his uncle fair
enough seems to me completely insane
that Joe Biden won't offer Secret
Service protection to a guy who's
polling 20% against him whose family has
been picked off by political assassins
for 70 years doesn't that seem a little
strange I'm glad Kennedy has a good
security team and I'm all for for
shrinking government spending but I
don't know I think especially now that
you had what sure seems to be an
assassin or two show up to the Ken the
event I'm willing for a few of my tax
dollars to go to to protect the major
presidential candidate and Democrat
threat to Joe Biden I think as we send a
hundred bazillion gazillion dollars
overseas to Vladimir zalinski to take on
the ruskies I think we can spend what's
it going to cost like a few hundred
grand to stop another Kennedy from being
assassinated seems like a good
investment to
me now speaking of things that begin
with K turning from the kennedies to
Kansas not my best transition Kansas
will no longer allow people
[Music]
to all it does is it means that an
important document in our
society
to convey facts and to ground Us in
reality will become
unreliable as has frequently been
happening now you know what is reliable
the quality of meat from good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
code NES we all have very busy schedules
soccer practice science fairs prepping
for the holidays Etc there's good news
you can take one big thing off your
plate by putting great meat on your
plate with good ranchers you care about
what your family eats and so does good
ranchers that's why they've spent years
building relationships with local farms
to Source the best 100% American beef
chicken pork now wild caught Seafood
they've added Seafood to the mix the
best of the land and sea can now get
conveniently delivered to your door and
right now they're offering two years of
free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that's a $480 value at a
locked in price 100% American meat it's
just insane no one else is offering
anything like this and no one else is
offering anything like this at the
Quality that good ranchers brings you I
adore it I eat it multiple times a week
and I would eat it more than that if uh
if I weren't traveling quite so much so
head on over to goodranchers.com use
code nolles 25 bucks off and free ground
beef for 2 years subscribe to any box to
lock in your price on America's best
meet for two whole years as well
goodranchers.com use code nolles for
over $500 in savings subscribed to good
ranchers American Meat delivered
speaking of
murder do you remember a story this was
from months and months ago I guess over
a year ago that Catholic schools in
Canada had been
murdering indigenous
children how is the story
this is two years ago a tribe in western
Canada announced that they had engaged
in some ground penetrating radar
investigation and discovered anomalies
in the soil around the schools and what
were those anomalies that they suspected
were Mass Graves where these Catholics
had been educating the indigenous
children at residential
schools and immediately all of the
liberal establishment in Canada flew
into action the Prime Minister lowered
Flags to half
staff the pope issued an apology all the
way from the Vatican and then this is
the most important part of the liberal
establishment springing into
action activists started burning down
Catholic churches because don't forget
the the liberal power structure it's not
just the elected people it's not just
the media it's not just the teachers
there's also the paramilitary wing in
America that's BLM that's antifa and in
Canada you have these these these
activists same same kinds of people they
burned churches all over Canada statues
were covered in graffiti statues were
pulled down Catholic statues for two
years this was going on because the
Catholic schools had been murdering all
these indigenous kids and burying them
in Mass Graves and then we turned out
that wasn't
true then we found Out oopsie Daisy yeah
none of that was true two years of
Investigations zero evidence that any of
that ever happened no Mass Graves
none now what did happen is the churches
burned
down and what did happen is the the
flags were lowered and the the statues
were pulled down and what did happen is
an actual blood liel was committed
against Catholics in Canada by the
liberal
establishment people who were going to
those churches they don't have churches
to go to
now but Oopsy Daisy no harm no foul
moving on
68 churches in Canada were Des
desecrated damaged or
destroyed and and is anyone going to be
held responsible for that no is Trudeau
Justin Castro you know the leader of
Canada is he going to
be prosecuted for spreading this Blood
liel
no any of the activists no you know what
they're going to do they're going to
move on to the next hoax and I tell you
the craziest thing is going to be
whatever the new bogus excuses the end
result is going to be the same statues
are going to come down churches are
going to burn Traditions are going to be
upended and the liberal project is just
going to go marching
on this is the this tribal Chief Derek
nepinak they've excavated 14 locations
under the church they got nothing now
speaking of Roman
things did you know that most men think
of the Roman Empire every single day
this fact has gone viral as a meme
because a woman asked her husband you
seen the Tik Tok where the woman says
did you know that most men think of the
Roman Empire daily and she asked her
husband and he says yes I do now I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
there is no way that my spouse thinks
about the Roman Empire
daily I asked my husband last night in
just and do you know what this man said
he said well in some capacity probably
every day why
so when I saw the meme go
around I I thought to myself because I
wasn't conscious of the fact that I
think of the Roman Empire every day but
I do the minute I saw it I said oh yeah
I guess I do what did do women not think
of the Roman Empire every day and then I
I was sitting at home and sweet little
Alisa turned to me she goes ma she saw
the meme she goes ma do you do you
really think of the Roman Empire every
day I thought girl I you live with me I
basically talk about about the Roman
Empire every day you kidding why is that
so why why do men think of the Roman
Empire every day it's to me it seems
pretty obvious because the Roman Empire
was the last time that we had a Unity
of all of Western Civilization a a a
perfect Unity of it you had a total
political Unity of all the lands and the
peoples you had a theological Unity
after the Edict of Milan after after uh
Catholicism then becomes the official
religion of the Roman Empire you have a
Unity of religion you have a Unity of
politics you have a Unity of land you
have a Unity of everything and then with
the fall of Rome which is the main
historical event that people compare
anything to then you see this breakup
that that you're always trying to get
back there was then a a a bit of a
Resurgence with the Holy Roman Empire
though I I consider that to be sort of
an extension of the Roman Empire and so
I think that think think that counts if
I think about the hapsburgs or something
I think I I think that qualifies as
thinking about the Roman Empire every
day but but Dante was writing about this
in the Middle Ages how there was just
this yearning in the western mind to
return to the Roman Empire because of
that Unity that we were all seeking
we're all just so frag and now we're so
extraordinarily fragmented that's why
that's why people make these comparisons
to the fall of Rome all the time because
they know that that was a bad thing but
but the the other side of the the men
think about Rome every day story and my
friend Spencer claven pointed this out
what so delightful about it is it's the
first time in a while we've seen one
sex stumble upon a fact about the
opposite sex and get a kick out of it so
often today when one sex finds out
something about the other sex or comes
to some observation about them it's it's
it's an observation made in disgust or
revulsion this is obviously true of the
feminists when they discover anything
masculine they call it toxic and it's
true even of the red pill bro men who
just don't like women that much and
attack women all the time but this is a
good example of women discovering
something that they previously didn't
know about men and thinking huh that's
kind of cute I don't know that's sort of
delightful it's kind of which is of
course how it's supposed to be because
men and women are different no matter
what our cultural Elites tell us today
and that differ is not a cause of pain
and revulsion and uh political problem
as our elates tell us today it's
actually a cause of delight in one of
the great one of the great aspects of
Life as a human being VI La
def speaking of men and women a story
that I'll touch on very briefly because
it would appear to be one of the top
stories in the news uh my friend Lauren
bobert has gotten in a bit of hot water
because there was a hid camera in a dark
theater catching her getting frisky or
something uh Lauren has since apologized
and she said yeah you know going through
stuff in my life and I fell into this
temptation of bad behaviors and anyway
I'm sorry it's really embarrassing and
really sad uh good enough for me good
enough some people were saying how could
anyone accept Lauren bobert's apology I
think well I don't because she's on our
team and it's not hypocritical to uh
extend a little bit more grace to the
people who are your allies that's called
politics first of all and it's a good
thing to do when your side is promoting
good things and the other side is
promoting very bad things I think if
someone AOL generally if people
apologize it's good to accept the
apology but certainly if it's someone on
your team I think that's fine and uh two
I think she is legitimately embarrassed
by it and we've all done embarrassing
things and we've all done a lot of
embarrassing things when we thought
thought we were sitting in the dark and
then when there are security cameras
that can see in the dark that uh can be
even more embarrassing and uh and also
the third reason and I think the the
strongest reason for accepting an
apology like this is Lauren is saying
look I I did something bad I fell short
of my standards and I'm ashamed of it
and I regret I regret falling into the
temptation of bad behavior for doing
things that the Liberals exalt as
positive
Goods anything you accuse Lauren of
doing the Liberals say is good it's
empowering it's it's wonderful it's
expressive it's virtuous and so when
they attack her for it it's obviously
disingenuous because the the only uh the
only crime according to the libs now is
hypocrisy by which they don't even
really mean hypocrisy they mean having
standards and failing them which is
called sinning which is called being
human so the only people who really
would have any standing to attack Lauren
for this are conservatives and had she
not apologized I would totally get it
but she apologized I think she's
embarrassed and I think it's fair enough
to uh you know move on we'll get to
women in politics and these double
standards in just a moment first though
how are your windows I think you got to
check out Renewal by Anderson right now
text nlls to 200 300 for most homeowners
window replacement is not something
they've done before for many it is not
something they want to do but something
they have to do if you've put off
replacing the windows in your home
because they're too expensive I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature renewal service
is committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product I got an email from a carpenter
who told me said Michael I heard you do
a read for Renewal by Anderson I'm just
telling you I go into houses they have
the best work of any windows that I see
and coincidentally I have a cousin who
works for them and has been telling me
about Renewal by Anderson for years even
before they were on the show so right
now they're offering a free inhome or
virtual consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for $0
down zero payments and zero interest for
one year text nolles kwes to 200 300 for
your free consultation to save 375 bucks
off every window and 750 bucks off every
door these savings will not last long so
be sure to check it out by texting
nolles to 200 300 that's nolles to 2300
texting privacy policy in terms and
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to window appointment now.com for full
offer details as you know the spooky
season is quickly approaching there will
be demons on the prowl just as there are
every day but I'm not just talking about
woke corporations that look upon your
beliefs with disdain no let's unwoke
Halloween with Jeremy's chocolate our
delicious chocolates come in two forms
he him with
nuts and she her not less just as our
Lord intended don't be a ghoul head on
over to Jeremy chocolate.com to order
your chocolates in time for
Halloween speaking of women in politics
and uh all sorts of Saucy things Su
Susanna Gibson I I now say initially I
didn't even want to say This Woman's
name on the show when the story came out
she's the Virginia House delegate
candidate who uh produced a lot of porn
of herself to make money um now I mean
the story is pretty in the mainstream I
don't think uh I don't think the cause
of is served all that much by not naming
her uh
Susanna uh was a porn performer until
very recently and uh did these things
with her husband and made money off of
it and off of these poor desperate guys
and now she's running for Virginia House
delegates well she she may have violated
the Commonwealth prostitution
laws uh Virginia law says that quote any
person who for money or its equivalent
engages in sexual intercourse or other
sexual acts with another person quote is
guilty of prostitution which is
punishable as a Class one misdemeanor a
former prosecutor Sean Klein and a
defense attorney in Virginia Beach said
it's his view that it is a chargeable
offense the statute is very clear he
says to the Daily wire you cannot for
money or its equivalent perform sex acts
doesn't matter who's paying for the ACT
if it's an observer or the recipient you
can't receive money okay so This Woman's
in hot water understandably I almost
feel bad for her cuz her culture is so
normalized porn that she probably never
thought that she was violating the law
uh but still very bad
thing my question on this has nothing to
do with the Virginia delegate race has
nothing to do with
Susanna how is porn legal how is porn
period legal it's apparently not legal
in Virginia how's it legal anywhere
prostitution is illegal most
places so if prostitution is illegal if
it's illegal to take money for sex acts
because it degrades the human person
reduces es the human being to nothing
but a mere object a sack of meat for
sensual pleasure and so because that is
degrading to everyone and degrading for
society and inflames lusts and vices
we've just had a law throughout the
country that that sort of thing is not
legal how is that all illegal but if you
put a camera in the room it's
legal doesn't make a lot of sense how is
it illegal to sell your body for sex to
one person but it's legal to sell your
body for sex to 10 million people
doesn't make a lot of sense
in recent years some extreme radical
liberals and Libertarians have argued
that porn is protected as free speech
that has never been true anywhere that
has never been true in any state that is
not that has nothing to do with the uh
traditional conception of free speech or
the First Amendment or any of those
things as even most Libertarians will
admit to appeals to the puran interest
obscenity are not protected speech so
why don't we use this kind of thing why
don't we use the case of Miss Susanna in
the house delegate race in Virginia as
what the libs call a teachable
moment and use the opportunity to rather
than F just I mean focus on the woman
get her out of the race do whatever but
maybe we use that to our advantage to
keep pressing forward on an issue on
which I think we will win now speaking
of missteps on issues that I think we
will win president Trump just got into a
bit of hot water I finally watched at
least part of the Megan Kelly interview
uh president Trump struggled to answer
if a man can become a woman can a man
become a
woman
um in my opinion you have a man you have
a woman I I I think I think part of it
is birth can the man give birth no no
although they'll come up with some
answer to that
also
it's not a great answer should be a
simple answer the answer
[Music]
is I just predict this will not hurt
Trump that much and maybe other
campaigns are going to be inclined to
shoot the messenger
but that prediction that I have been
making for over a year now has
consistently proven to be true
okay speaking of Republicans making
missteps that today is just deal with
Republicans missteps day uh there's a
report allegedly it's a report I don't
know if it's true could be completely
bogus and I have no reason to believe
that it's true but anyway it's the
report and it's a big news story uh
allegedly Christine Nome Republican
governor of South Dakota is having an
extramarital affair you see plenty of
sex scandals in politics uh why is the
story coming out now it seems pretty
clear to me the reason is that South
Dakota governor Christine n just
endorsed Donald Trump and 5 seconds
later there's a news
report almost certainly dug up by Oppo
researchers that uh she or planted to or
fabricated that uh she's having an
extramarital affair okay I don't know if
it's true I'm not interested in the
story if they prove it without a shadow
of a doubt they got her dead to wrs okay
that's her political career again I'm
not really focused on that kind of thing
the story is inter ing to me because
these things do happen so whether or not
it's true of chrisy gome we've seen this
story what hundred times before a
thousand times before some politician on
top of the world big Ambitions throws it
all away for a sex scandal you think of
Mark Sanford remember that guy governor
of South Carolina just ran away from the
governor's mansion to have an affair
with some lady in South
America you I mean people do this time
and time again and my takea away from
that is it requires
intense effort and discipline and prayer
for God's grace not to act like a total
idiot our inclination our human nature
is such in this Fallen world that we are
at every
moment deeply inclined to act like
complete idiots and to throw away all
the good stuff we have for
nothing for momentary pleasure with
degenerates all of us we are all
inclined that way and if you think
you're not if you're the kind of person
who oh no I would I treat my job too
seriously oh I would never cheat on my
spouse oh not me not me then you're the
most likely to do
it these are people it's Drew claven
observes this and there's a a famous
joke about a guy who has an orange for a
head and the punch line I won't even
tell the whole joke the punch line is
how did the guy how the guy wind up with
an orange for head he asked for
it that's the perversity of human nature
in a Fallen World don't do it do not
whatever the momentary pleasure is I Pro
Look it's easier said than done but I
promise you it will not be worth the
shame and the embarrassment and throwing
away all the good stuff you've got do
not do it and the way to stop yourself
from doing it is to avoid the occasion
of sin and the way to do that is to
cultivate habits of virtue and Tamp down
habits of vice and most of all to pray
for grace my favorite comment on Friday
is from cools and Hots who says Dove
gave her this was a fat Liberation
activist Dove gave the fat Liberation
activist an endorsement because they
figured that her followers can get more
soap over much more body thus increasing
profitability it's a brilliant Theory
and that's capitalism folks that's how
capitalism works so so true speaking of
women not looking so great now we turn
our attention to the Democrats AOC just
got shouted down in New York over the
issue of immigration
close the B close the B close the border
close the
[Applause]
[Music]
B right I can't even hear a which is
fine by me it's Bri you can hear those
women than you get the point you can
hear those women chanting those are not
right
Republicans shipped up from Texas okay
they don't have a Tennessee accent those
are New Yorkers I'm look I'm a New
Yorker by birth and upbringing there are
plenty of conservative normal people in
New York were just drowned out
politically by the crazy
Libs but those are normal New Yorkers
who show up and they say hey close the
border even Eric Adams the liberal
Democrat mayor is saying that
immigration is going to destroy New York
City because the country is getting
flooded because the the southern
borderers open and the the Republican
Governors down south have had enough of
it they're not going to deal with it on
their own they're going to ship them up
to New York and reoboth Beach and
Martha's
Vineyard th this has always been the the
trick of immigration for the Democrats
immigration is great for the Democrats
long term but immigration is very bad
short
term longterm it gives them more voters
and I know Ronald Reagan said that
Hispanics are Republicans they just
don't know it yet well he said that in
what 1982 and we're still waiting I'm
still it's been 40 years 41 years now we
still they haven't turned Republican
yet some Hispanic voters have shifted a
little bit depending on the election
certain groups of Hispanics tend to be
more Republican than others like the
Cubans but broadly speaking Democrats
know that Hispanic migration across the
southern border is a net Boon for them
that's why they encourage it that's the
only reason that they encourage it but
short term Democrats don't like the
chaos that this
causes because the effects of migration
despite what we we've been told are not
generally positive in fact you hear this
from Karen bass who's not only a liberal
out in California she's actually a
communist she worked for communist
organizations she is a radical leftist
she was a member of Congress now she is
the mayor of Los Angeles and here's her
somewhat contradictory take on migration
what they're trying to do is
destabilized cities because it's Chicago
it's Washington DC it's New York it's
the Nar that these are democratic run
cities and that we don't know how to
govern and that everything is chaotic
here we live in a city that welcomes
immigrants and so I think we have been
able to handle it but I am fearful that
any day planes could start
coming why are you
fearful why are you fearful that this
wonderful thing could come to your city
because you see immigration is good
that's why you welcome immigrants it's
good diversity is our strength We're a
nation of immigrants you oh good let's
have more Nation let's have more
strength why are you
fearful that all these this good thing
would happen to you why would it be
chaotic it's strength strength isn't
chaotic strength is strong
Cooperative
edifying Democrats are very worried that
this could be a big election issue
that's what this is
about
they they have been
surreptitiously changing the voting base
of the United States for 60 years now
and when
that immigration issue I can't call it a
trickle it was a lot more than a trickle
but it was still largely unnoticed it
was a thousand people a
day500 people a day certainly about when
it was 500 people to day then it got to
be 2,000
3,000
4,000 5,000 then then it got to be
insane surges of migrants with no end in
sight and the people noticed and people
noticed and they started to turn on it
this is the same thing with the LGBT
movement when it was just uh you know
Greenwich Village when it was just uh
willing Grace on TV when it was just
something that consenting adults did
privately most people didn't
care the moment that idea ology entered
the classroom especially the younger
classrooms that was the flip that was
the the binary switch of people noticing
speaking of global politics before we go
we'll zoom out to the 30,000 foot
view is a headline in Bloomberg World
disappointed by the UN now looks
Elsewhere for
answers a brutal grinding war in Ukraine
governments overthrown in Niger and
Gabon lingering hostility over the co 19
pandemic and the unequal distribution of
life-saving
vaccines yeah uhhuh with dozens of world
leaders deciding upon New York for the
UN General assembly's annual Gathering
Global problems are showing up fast and
Thick at the world body's door with no
Solutions in sight many countries are
starting to look elsewhere to do
something about them yes that's true
that's always got to happen the notion
of the United Nations is politically
incoherent the only thing even
potentially recommending the United
Nations is that it is a front group for
us hegemony around the world it is it is
just a facade in front of you the us as
an imperial power imposing its its
Vision on the world and uh attacking its
enemies and supporting its friends if
the UN is not just that if the UN is
really supposed to be some kind of world
government where we're all citizens of
the world singing Kumbaya holding hands
then then it is completely incoherent
and completely impossible because
politics requires a distinction between
your allies and your enemies it it has
to because you have to
know in as much as people disagree about
anything in as much as people have
interests and desires and faculties of
reason and disagree because this is a
fallen world and our faculties of Reason
aren't always perfect and our perception
sometimes has defects in as much as man
Remains the political animal as
Aristotle called us then politics will
be a team sport we will disagree we'll
form coalitions to deal with those
disagreements and figure out how to live
together and in as much as that occurs
we are not all going to be unified all
the nations of the earth it is not
possible the libs are going to lament
the decline of the UN as a as a politics
making body for the whole
world it never really was that and what
what the libs are really lamenting is
the decline of their own power and the
people of the world in whose name the
Liberals supposedly govern and rule the
people saying hey this is not working
for us anymore so then the Liberals will
try to Tamp that down and they'll say
that's populism that's nationalism
that's this ISM that's that ISM what
does that mean it means nations want to
have their own Nations what does
populism mean it means the people want
to have a say in government
these are these are just terms of insult
these are just slurs hurled about by
people who who I think have been caught
as Emperors without clothes the rest of
the show continues now it's music Monday
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code noes canw a check out
for two months free on all annual
[Music]
plans